So far we added code to put
one event into the data layer,
just used by one trigger, and to trigger
two hits to analytics as a result.
And we did this because I wanted you
to see that a trigger can be used
to trigger more than one thing, but stop
and think about whether it really makes
sense to track the opening of
an activity in multiple ways like this.
On the one hand,
we track the button clicks for
the Show Daily Special button.
But on the other hand, we track
the Show Daily Special screen views.
Really, we should only send one hit,
when the user clicks
the Show Daily Special button.
Which tag do you think is
the right one to use in this case?
Go ahead and discuss in the forum.